hi everyone and welcome back to the
games with stage here at e3 2017 joining
joining Tamar and I is URI from house
mark hello welcome feel to be here and
you're gonna be showing us matter fold
yeah so I mean let's don't jump right in
double jump Friday
that's great Oriole now um yeah so I
mean what's what's the basic premise so
basic premise is in its core to mat
matter fall is a twin stick shooter we
had a lot of elements from from like
platformer games and bullet hell games
it's like combination of lots of genres
right so this these kind of arcade-style
games are completely your Studios jam
like you this is what you kind of
specialize in I really like how you guys
are kind of mixing up the formula
because you know you've had ship
shooters and now you're doing this what
were kind of your key inspirations for
this game I'm seeing this and I'm
looking and thinking of you know Metroid
in that Cup Metroid and like to recon
and like contra and run on ground games
like gun star heroes oh I like of course
like bullet hell games like it like a
radiant Silvergun and okay a little that
quite old school inspiration right so
let's see what's the story so how is all
of this able to happen mmm Oh about the
game story yeah yeah yeah your play as
you play as a Avalon Darrow a hired
mercenary who's top is the clear out the
CT about the evil red matter the
basically the city has has been built
upon like this blue matter and if coach
corrupt the corrupted and took to
correct those you can see those red
enemies there so basically your job is
to clear them you can save all the
civilians from this Ryan the levels so
can you manipulate the bloom are you
sure the red yeah you can actually
create like platforms out the perimeter
and you use that you'd like your
advantage like it build up shields and
like a better platform right see this
the color stuff um it's just reminding
me of a carrucha quite a bit yeah so did
you play a lot of that to kind of yeah
of course I never like former game like
Outland
yeah watch based on yeah I connect a man
I love the Outlands you know what okay
bring that back but yes I'll talk about
briefly about the mechanics that you
kind of got going here cuz you're a very
mechanic at least yeah I guess a
basically you're you are this is like a
shooter you shoot with a like a right
stick and then we have a lot lots of
like sec
the ribbons like this grenade that we
are using here and then we have this
matter gun that matter said that we are
just used to explode those bombs there
right and you can choose up to three
different augmentations they can be like
passive augmentation they can be the
weapons but you can switch at free okay
cool and what kind of augmentations are
available to you what he allowed would
they allow you to do yeah so basically
the weapons are you have this homing
weapon or called seeker and for worship
that is like basically a piercing weapon
and then basic shotgun and the grenade
launcher okay yeah and the passive
augmentations are like they are
increasing you're like that explosion
and you can trigger different stuff and
get extra help and better reloads for
your secondary fires so there's like
lots of combinations that you can try
right yeah an obviously movement is a
big part you have the ability to kind of
change the way you kind of get around
yeah well you have the basic double jump
then but then we have this core mechanic
called strike that you can basically
strike everywhere like you just sort of
striking through blue matter right now
basically the strike is your like part
of your core movement you can stun
enemies with it and kill enemies easily
and that's what we're seeing that lies
ahead on your face basically you want to
the player use the strike as a offensive
mode right it's like you basically
turning in this bit hair you're turning
the character into almost like a shapee
but yeah it's a resolute loading around
and yeah it's really cool yeah
everything we just like you can
destroyed all the bullets and yeah right
right and how does the progression work
in this game is it like a level by level
four level and when you save the
civilians you get the augmentations
so basically explore the levels and get
the highest describe but it's but
there's no like overarching world that
you're moving between notes you know
like one after the other one after that
okay cool yeah and I guess that allows
you to do crazy things with like scenes
and that way I feel level yeah we have
to have like we have three different
themes that we have the city that we are
currently in then we have the second
level is coming it's hydroponics there's
a plant crawl place yeah it's lots of
like environment affect folks and stuff
right yes
interesting throughout playtesting have
there been combinations that you maybe
haven't anticipated that people would
come up with yeah there there there are
yeah because of the different
augmentations when you put them together
you get totally different game plan okay
so they've been been lots of like tuning
to get that get them right so one of the
things I'm noticing is your games are
often the longevity in them comes
through the score checking and that kind
of stuff how have you introduced that
element of it into this game so so
basically to get the highest score you
need to use the overcharge mechanic that
we have so every enemy that you kill and
drop these blue orbs when you collect
them you can activate overcharge
okay and that means that time slows down
and you can kill the enemies faster so
you get to have a higher higher score so
you just need to know when to use them
okay and you anticipate that's going to
be what people will be score chasing
with yeah if you want to get the highest
score you need to know how to use that
yeah is there any sort of multiplayer
component noticing the pre-roll you have
the leaderboards to sort yeah later for
support
yeah for their like global leaderboards
okay cool it's interesting so we're
moving on to another yeah the game level
this is the hydrophone hydroponics okay
so what's the deal with this level how
does this fit into the the story of the
game yeah basically this is a place
where the oxygen is made made falta like
the city so basically that this is like
layered seating you up first in the city
then you are on the hydroponics level
and the third place is the black mines
or like underground okay cool I mean
just looking at it it's um
it could mean an astonishing number of
particle effects yes and I mean you guys
have your particle yeah we love all of
your particle effects was this more or
less a challenge than in previous games
cuz it just seems like there's so much
more going on yeah yeah getting the
clarity right is one what was a big job
so you can put some particles in but if
you don't know what's going to happen
what's happening in the screen surfer
that that was a big challenge I guess
yeah that comes must be interesting to
try and balance that with the design of
a bullet sure yeah element because those
games are all about overwhelming you and
Joanna give you making you find the
small break in order yeah how did you
kind of balanced feeling like a bullet
hell shooter but also making sure the
clarity is there yeah it
it was just trial and error and lots of
iteration right getting the chlorides
getting the particle amount right right
yeah okay interesting
so do you know how long this kind of how
many levels there are going to be in
this game or you'll get all of doing
tuning tuning the difficulty and other
levels so we are not getting an ounce in
the level okay cool is there just one
difficulty level or can you there's a
really decent of difficulty level right
like basic easy medium hard but when you
finish the game we unlock this insane
mode then okay then you have one bar of
health and revenge bullets for every
enemy right so it's a super hard mode
that sounds like something I'll never
play I'm glad you have it in there very
hardcore player yeah so you feel about
whether people like in the speedrunning
community we're gonna be interested in
this yeah it seems like a girl because
to eat runnable game yeah this is pretty
honorable game and all the levels are
built for speedrunning
okay you can basically just dash through
everything and try to kill everything on
your way right and you have the fastest
time on the level it's cool I love the
way this decide on kind of light games
look like this and yeah it's reminding
me of that some Microsoft shadow complex
a lot quite a bit and so I'm seeing in
them it looks super active I love the
kind of feeling so you got it guys are
kind of big into making sure bullet
impact and that kind of stuff is kind of
like really felt how have you kind of
approach that in this game it's easy to
do like a ship place a little more
tricky when you've got more things
blowing up and you've got yeah you're
gonna need to have a like butta if I put
feedback on everything right all the
like bullet hits needs to be shown and
yeah when you get the damage you that is
it's us about the feedback right right
okay cool thing it's correct so
basically there we can see the civilian
out on that purple criminal when you
save that you get the reward
so basically augmentation from from
toast right and say is that the kind of
like the end of the stage once you find
civilian or does it like they are like I
don't know they hidden around yeah so
okay I simply have to find some to get
the right okay so now you have two
secret weapon right yeah how long how
long is is each level roughly I think
that first left was about five minutes
but I mean yeah basic level is about 15
to 25 minutes yet so I mean like how do
you balance um you know giving players a
good amount of content in one love
with like intensity right because you
know it looks incredibly a how do you
kind of make sure that players don't
I mean burnout to maybe not the right
word but don't become over burden yeah
yeah well we have a little like smaller
moments and then if you have these
moments where okay yeah I name is coming
all around so we are trying to balancer
that putting some like high in test
moments into levels but then like just
like basic platforming sections also
you're not constantly shooting
everything right it's interesting you
we're seeing the player creating
platforms it is it always defined where
the platter yeah okay cool and but you
don't have used and they are usually or
you can like set up or different rules
with them right basically you can just
skip them or use them as the shield
right okay so it's more that you can use
in strategically the energetically yeah
a war between you and all the bullets
and that kind of stuff okay is there any
kind of like puzzle solving elements or
are you trying to intangible momentum
which yeah really streamlined action
okay yeah that's interesting is that the
same for kind of like the platforming
elements of it because yeah you know
place basically what we could soon see
is that we have a like conveyor belts
and stuff like that like basic
platforming elements that gives us the
flavor for the level right okay cool
it's cool Wow Stargate yeah yeah star
yes yeah right and so are there like
boss characters cuz I'm not seeing any
so far yeah it's like little demi boss
yeah these are like a bigger enemies so
that does the shield guy what that we
saw and there's a bigger spider but then
we have like three different bosses that
are like huge process okay so each each
team has their own boss boss fight right
okay
and is just exclusively for the
PlayStation exclusive replace dang know
via version know movie what's going on
it does see like I was looking and
thinking really gonna enjoy playing this
on my Vita and then I remember oh wait a
second yeah that's that's unfortunate
but yeah okay there's the rates matter
that is like a crystal that's the
corrupt that matter right okay so your
role is to get rid of that yeah get rid
of that avoid that and you throw this
red matter anime so and we're seeing
like enemies explode into a lot of these
kind of little particle things just is
that Justin
factor is that something that you'll be
able to like use in terms of gameplay is
also a factor okay cool basically
reactive player is soft for the like eye
candy right okay yeah we're always on
board of like yeah yeah I can't let's go
what we seen here now yeah different
types of enemies you've got a look at
like that venomous so what kind of
different types of enemies you have say
one looks like a quite defensive one we
get it as requires you can get yeah you
cannot shoot it from this because it's a
scale so you can utilize two like the
Kranitz that bounce or jump in the back
oh wow yeah yeah do you see it okay so
you're building so how do you how are
the kind of enemies places is something
that you kind of designed an algorithm
to take care of where you kind of hand
click a hanpan placed that then we have
this like spawning system like you can
see here those are good enemies they're
like if you get why spawns okay yeah and
then we have it that the persistent
enemies that arts or right-hand beat the
hand placed on the levels dama doesn't
that must make tuning the game quite
difficult cuz you're never quite sure
you have this like random element to it
yeah so they'll worry that there's a
part of the game somewhere that just is
incredibly difficult that you know about
we've been tuned to this game like a
perfection so okay cool so yeah how long
you've been working on it yeah two years
now well with the theme size of maximum
20 people 20 people yeah okay cool is
this is this the only game in
development at the studio are you kind
of working at other thing they actually
help the next wash you're not coming
okay oh yeah oh yeah that's interesting
wow so except there's the corn Boyer
belts and stuff alright so that's not
like yeah I've only tried former
Yugoslavia so it looks very much like
classic bullet-hell shooters worth
trying to overwhelm you but not too much
and giving you enough to kind of balance
together platforming and kind of
escaping through hails of bullet
and that's another is there no can you
like miss a lot of these civilians well
you can but via we have a like sound
effect and hard elements popping when
you are near the civilian auto so we
want you to find them but there are
usually and behind of some kind of
challenge so or not like the golden path
so is it possible to kind of return to a
level and yeah pickup you think I love
the music music TV now can you obey no
you can see on the heart on the right
top right corner that how many civilians
you right
I won't be um saving the teensies yeah
yeah like Rayman Origins yeah all
teensies going help me what are those
things that you picking up because he
looks like pies but I'm assuming no pies
oh you mean those blue warp yeah the
orange orb is that what kind of floating
around Orient orb
oh yeah I guess it were any Me's then
yeah you do anyone ever like a nice
right they look like prices run again so
like for a pie pie yeah I'm sure you can
go back to the studio and really change
these two pies no please okay this is
the like the classic a bullet L place
that right there's lots of enemies lots
of bullets so this really like you need
to know what you're doing here yeah and
and you've got a strict health system
where it's like yeah like hovering is it
no no you the ones you go like like help
orbs that enemies are right up okay and
what's the blue bar underneath the
health yeah it's the overcharge bar okay
let go like those blue orbs and it gets
filled - you can actually still win
right yeah and every time he dashes it
sends out like a shock wave yeah I know
it does explode - explosion against
enemies destroy bullets and it's us the
easier way to get around okay so you
have to actually take a risk and - yeah
yeah at basic - today enemies all right
you need score when in doubt use the -
okay so it works as a defensive and
offense and of like ya think okay that's
whether you can dodge but we it's better
that the - straight to the enemies right
they close and then we're finished with
the guns and is there any kind of like
chain combo system or not maybe like
what not basically about that what we
are going in the score mechanic that
they you need to kill enemies fast what
they activate be fast on the killing you
get a higher score when you kill into
the fire right and it's like multipliers
and yeah multipliers there are ya know
each difficulty has their own multiplier
so if you want to have the best score
you need to play with the highest
difficulty right yeah okay cool
what's been the biggest challenge in
bringing multiple to reality yeah
because you've had a lot of experience
with the PlayStation yeah well yes I've
been yeah on this game of maybe it may
be defining the fun that because we have
lots of elements we have the platforming
we have bullet shell and so getting it
to feel right right yeah it was like
under loss of tuning
and I guess it must be difficult there
must be some sort of like though about
maybe people won't respond to every
element of the game because some people
like platforming some people aren't
bullet hole fans but it hills are quite
a nice Jean yeah and it can be quite
stressful to play there yeah so have you
thought about how you kind of present
that and balance that for people who
don't like every element of that that's
why the levels are like usually say like
there's multiple sections so you are not
constantly getting the same thing so
it's not constantly two bullet tells
right I don't contemplate the
platforming it's like mix of mix of
those elements okay where are we going
to now now we are going to the first
boss okay so it's alright this is one of
the big bosses yeah this is the big boy
okay cool
so good yeah it wasn't through it's a
Washburn I see I'm all ready I don't
like this one bit is there a reason that
the enemy seemed to be very insect focus
diving yeah it's it it's a very draw to
inspiration so they look like menacing
under cool like see insects insects suck
yeah everyone hates insects there's no
one out there that enjoys seeing a wasp
yeah indeed I don't real life usually
the best episodes of like planet Earth
yeah yeah I mean there's no gas scenario
where someone's hat was final Phoenix
yeah exactly yeah
say you are a final in sexing you know
not fun oh no yes go be someone at the
team if yeah it's over over again but
yeah yeah so a boss battle looks like a
lot of yeah you having recognition and
classic boss yeah classic like a classic
boss boss different so basically have to
utilize your jumping here you're dancing
here and all the moments right and I
guess the all the bosses will be
similarly a do they kind of don't they
are the difference yeah we're right yeah
so each team has like own boss and it
should feel like it belongs to that team
yeah all right yeah do they kind of as
you go along
account for because all these bosses are
designed to challenge your mastery of
movement and shooting that kind of stuff
but you have the opportunity to change
some of that the way you you know the
way you upgrade and kind of progress so
get the bosses going forward kind of
account that you may have a different
style of play and try and challenge that
as well or is it like yeah fundamentals
a v8
yeah it's a fundamental so okay yeah
okay cool basic basically you can try
different kind of augmentation combos
and see what's worked with the best with
you
okay cool so this wasp is looks like
he's stressing me out without that's
like I'm already like I - listen it
looks writing yeah this is cool
yeah yeah all right oh wow
is that it oh no no no okay token phases
and yet Hannah stuff okay otherwise
let's go see you guys you need to maybe
like that one tree to another doing it
yeah yeah I mean our friend over there
demoing is probably an expert at this
yeah so he's like no so yeah yeah so we
are seeing a master at Fitchburg right
all right no pressure no pressure
yeah Wow so the game runs actually on 60
frame per seconds right yeah and okay on
bass ps4 just beautiful program good
bolt oh okay oh it's the Esper oh we
have a like a better a higher resolution
yeah and better like environment effects
and increase particle counts right but
the gameplay experience is the same yeah
and this is a game that you intend on
kind of supporting for a while with
extra content and that kind of worth we
have no blast for deals okay so you're
building as a fully form yeah yeah it's
a fully formed games that you can play
from start to finish
okay cool that's interesting it's
getting a bit busy now and yeah yeah
it's stressing me a lot yeah yeah it's
all that high cause like I think you
guys need to relax on the particles yeah
it's freaking me out
yeah right oh and he's gone
no he's back going keep lucky that the
health bar is just underneath the table
so I can't see it like I have to stand
up like I love you still alive you still
there that's cool I like to mix of kind
of like platforming and how it's kind of
diverting your attention away from
platforming at the same time as at the
same time as you know needing you to
actually attack the enemy those are the
things that get me and it's a and it's
the skill that you have to build to do
it may remember to shoot as well as a
zombie oh yeah and I guess that's the
kind of a lot of your games are about
that like figuring out trying to access
different parts of your skillset and
that was what resogun really spoke to me
I have one of the first games on the ps4
that I kind of got obsessed with it was
like it made me felt like I was becoming
a bad game
playing yeah it was like yeah you were
learning pipe later yeah I think the
skills I learned from playing resogun
have transferred into many other games
yeah I guess I think I can all my
overwatch abilities my abilities to hit
things are more raining blood yeah
exactly why do you think people resonate
with the the leaderboard aspect so much
because I mean yeah we have friends that
just would be like okay yeah other games
coming up but I'm gonna I'm still on
Rezac I'm still gonna hit that I think
it's the competition feel that you can
be best at anything and you see your
progression and how you compare to other
players yeah though as another studio do
you guys see that you kind of stay you
guys are keeping like the classic arcade
game alive and yeah obviously you're
huge fans of it but are you kind of like
I actually see a awesome explosion okay
good and it's the boss behind that's
perfect for me like do you guys
anticipate you carry on making these
that was developed insane by the way
yeah I wasn't saying yeah so the you
guys anticipate you carry on making
these kind of arcade style game yeah or
are you building up to something that's
gonna be huge triple A or something well
let's see what's okay coming off you
have an ambition to do that yeah yeah
yeah yeah
okay that'll be interesting to see in
the future then yeah well thank you so
much for joining us when can we get our
hands on matter yeah August 15 our North
America and August 16 on Europe yeah
well thank you so much joining us yeah
guys don't go anywhere in a matter of
moments we're gonna be having Metroid
Samus returns here on the game sports
dream let's keep your eyes peeled
you